so leute ich habe die pizza isst
rausgeholt und natürlich ich muss ganz
ehrlich und offen zugeben dass wir was
der jura auch schon gesagt hat das ist
mir ein bisschen mission so und ich bin
jetzt nicht der perfekte pizza backen
aber komm mal her komm mal kurze und
jetzt riecht man nicht mal da und du
kannst jetzt nicht sagen dass das nicht
lecker wie willkommen beim ein video
leute ich hoffe euch jetzt gut nach
alter ich bin heute einfach rot ich muss
gerade kurz mal ein bisschen auf meine
haut achten weil ich gerade mein
experiment mache ein neues kommt sonntag
online ich will euch noch nicht genau
verraten worum es geht aber vielleicht
erkennen als schon ganz gut weil
eigentlich nicht ich will auch gar nicht
lange lagern und zwar kennt ihr mich ja
ich bin jemand ich komme auf die
verrücktesten ideen und heute habe ich
wieder was echt krass vor und zwar kam
mir gestern die seele einfach mal ein
neues fenster video zu machen
heute geht es aber nicht um ganz
einfache pizza sondern wie es am titel
wahrscheinlich schon gelesen habt wir
machen heute eine mac gespitzelt zu
übertrieben ich hab so was zumindest
aber auf youtube noch nie gesehen und ja
deswegen wir fahren los für die aktion
auf jeden fall schon mal vor wir gehen
es erstmals zum rewe holen den teig und
so weiter einfach mal zu meckern paar
sachen die wir drauf tun werden weiß ich
noch nicht so ganz schick daher was
meint er es damit ihr werden dass gleich
sehen ja viel spaß mit dem video bis
schläuchen
so leute ich habe eingekauft und zwar
haben wir hier ist schon einmal so eine
pizza kit mit einem pizzateig und
tomatensoße und dann noch fehlen darf
natürlich nicht fehlen
aber jetzt kommt das wichtigste also
let's go herzlich willkommen bei
mcdonald ihre bestellung bitte hallo ich
hätte gern einen bigmac menü
cola catcher bitte und dazu kommen dann
noch einmal die ziele des neckars
fünfstück bitte das wäre es uns schon
danke
eine sehr bezaubernde stimme
sollte alles was man auf jeden fall mal
sagen muss das ist dieser weg ist hier
ja da ist auf jeden fall in köln mein
lieblingswerk david auf jeden fall daran
ist wenn er vom kölner stadion die
mitarbeiter sind alle sehr freundlich
und zwei davon kennt mich sogar ich bin
da ich war dann halt manchmal durch ein
mc drive und irgendwie keine ahnung von
einem monat oder so kommt er mich sagen
sagt du bist doch dieser youtube für
dich immer echt ganz witzig weil man
erneut halt schon irgendwie ein bisschen
älter sind oder so
das ist ja auf jeden fall ab jetzt ein
geschaut und mir denke ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich was hat alex vor ihr
werde das gleich sehen
viel spaß so leute ich bin zurück haben
jetzt alles auf jeden fall muss ich mich
jetzt mit kapellen aus welchem grund
werde sofort erfahren und ich hoffe dann
wird das was cool ist kann man ja auch
vielleicht lacht man machen dass man
seine subway pizzeria ja auch mal wie
ihr könnt ja auf jeden fall mal in die
kommentare schreiben was ihr davon
haltet also hier haben gestern abend
auch unser bild und jetzt ist es da
so leute herzlich willkommen in meiner
tasche wird sagen wir fangen heute mal
an ich hab schon so lange keinen
pizzateig selber mehr gemacht deswegen
bin ich erst mal gespannt ob das
überhaupt was wird da kriege ich das
zumindest sagt jetzt nicht dafür braucht
man einen dosenöffner
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so kannst du nicht hallo
habt ihr mich war leute wie mich gedacht
die zu hause keinen dosenöffner haben
obst pro juli meine einzige befürchtung
ist jetzt nur dass ich irgendwie brauche
ich brauche dafür mehr dass das nicht
festklebt scheiße den kann man ja so
ausrollen moment also ich bin halt
wirklich nicht so der beste pizza bäcker
das muss man auch ganz offen und ehrlich
mal zu geben
deswegen machen wir hier jetzt erst mal
eine schöne runde pizza falls sich das
irgendwie hinkriegen sollte ach weißte
was
isabella jetzt scheißegal wir machen das
jetzt einfach hier optimistisch und
diese längliche form ist mir auch egal
das ist nämlich viel zu dick ist brauche
ich nicht so was ich mache mein eigenes
ding hier jetzt denkt euch
wahrscheinlich behoben ein alex das ist
total falsch das wird nichts ich mache
jetzt hier nämlich gerade den rand das
ist das allerwichtigste für mich bei
einer pizza der unteren jetzt gibt es
kein zurück mehr weil ich denke es ist
schon so verklebt leichthändig da sofort
irgendwie nicht unterlegt so leute ist
mir egal fang jetzt einfach an wenn es
klappt dann klappt es wenn nicht dann
klappt's möglich und als erstes brauchen
wir mal ein bisschen tomatensoße ich
weiß nicht ob da alles tun muss besser
nicht so sagt ja ich sage das vielleicht
erst mal und als nächstes brauchen wir
logischerweise ist brauche ich eine
schere
aber wofür eine schere wenn es auch so
geht euch liebe ja diesen kirchen also
machen wir hier mal ein bisschen rauch
nicht zuviel warum sich begleitet so und
jetzt hätten wir ja eine ganz einfache
pizza margarita
aber ich habe ja schon gesagt wir machen
heute einen meckern
und sagt wir haben ein paar sachen
geholt und ja die comments oder auch ich
würde sagen wir fangen erst mal ganz
leicht an mit ein paar pommes
ich finde dass sie schon wieder gut aus
sollten nicht das habe ich fünf tore
schießen der kasko die sind mehr gut die
gibt es ja auch bei mcdonald ist
übrigens kein plätzchen das video ich
mag es einfach so weil ich lust drauf
habt und das gute an diesen dingern ist
wenn man die auf markt kammern
normalerweise die ist chili cheese zeug
einfach so raus pressen wenn die frisch
sind geht das zumindest also in den
dünger ist halt einfach so käse drin und
halt auch so ein paar chili stück höher
aber die schmeckt man kommt ja leute gut
dass sich das gerade nicht so lecker aus
ich würde sagen das reicht erst mal
einen es sich selber so ich muss ich
erst mal kurz händewaschen
so leute und als rechts ist dann habe
ich noch ein big mac os also ich bin ich
nicht so mega der big bag fällen nur
wieso weshalb school deswegen kommt
einfach mal ein bisschen von dieser soße
auch noch auf die pizza und haben wir
doch ein bisschen salat kauf und damit
es noch ein bisschen mehr nach einer
global schmeckt tue ich auch noch so ein
bisschen was von big mac trauer also in
sich haben jetzt ein ganz kleines
bisschen fleisch mit auf der pizza finde
ich nicht so gut aber man kann es mal
probieren so dumm das ganze jetzt
abzuschließen kommen noch ein paar
pommes oben drüber bei uns auf jeden
fall laufen bisschen käse ja heute also
höre ich auf jeden fall mal die spitze
an sie das gerade vom namen so aus
so leute also die pizza ist jetzt gerade
was drin ist ein bisschen blöd unser
offen ist gerade kaputt deswegen haben
wir hier so einen übergangs dingen es
wird auf jeden fall schon ziemlich gut
die wird nur recht dick ich hoffe ich
kriege die darauf leben wieder raus also
fürs nächste mal müssen wir auf jeden
fall merken dass man diese pizza besser
nicht übereinander tut sondern einfach
schön ausbreitet damit dann halt auch
gleich richtig aufgehen können aber so
ist es halt
hallo ich will nicht so sein
was so leute ich hab die pizza isst
rausgeholt und natürlich ich muss ganz
ehrlich und offen zugeben was was der
juli auch schon gesagt hat das ist mir
ein bisschen mission so und ich bin
jetzt nicht der perfekte pizza backen
aber komm her komm mal kurz r und jetzt
riecht mal nicht und du kannst jetzt
nicht sagen dass das nicht länger bieten
bundesrichters nach nachricht ich keine
pizza alter jetzt war uns spaß aber was
hast du da gemacht dass sie aus liebe
dich links und junger leute was denn für
diese pizza aber mindestens mindestens
15.000 likes oder restaurants an die
leute seid ihr bereit für meine
mcdonald's pizza 32
[Musik]
inzwischen bei uns in der regel aber das
riecht so gut malta ohne witz aber
ehrlich das war doch nicht schlecht oder
weil ich weiß was da draußen will ich
nicht isst du willst mir ernsthaft sagen
dass sie nicht länger aus und geht das
zu grün
ja das ist salat wehrmacht salat
hausbesitzer von dem big mac und wieso
sollte ich würde sagen schmeckt spucke
einmal versteht nicht warum erkennt mir
sonne möge gehen damit man du wirst es
nicht anprobieren richtig natürlich euch
hier leben möchte man hier
durchschneiden
[Musik]
dann können wir das jetzt glaubt oder
nicht aber ich finde das ist wirklich
was weg ist also ich finde man kannst du
nicht zulassen das schmeckt gut wo wir
einmal elcom enthüllt sich prächtig
nicht nur schlecht so wenig junge
bassisten schmeckt folgen der normale
pizza naja leute dann ist das eben so
ich freue mich jetzt auf mein
mittagessen ich hab das video hat euch
ein bisschen unterhalten ihr könnt ja
meine kommentare schreiben was ihr davon
haltet man kann ja auch andere sache
draus machen das hatte ich gesagt stopps
hamburger so schreibe es in die
kommentare oder hassen nach oben jackson
hat schon ernster gemacht ganz wichtig
wir sehen uns morgen wieder
morgen gibt's neues video